Bloomberg
[Musique]
et Nick Magician vidéo ni mesdames ni messieurs
tu veux changer d'univers
viens avec moi en martinique el meson del
oublié
[Musique]
et
et que
[Musique]
mais
Si la diva ne se répète pas
Je dirais sans fin
si tu m'écris
[Musique]
la vie
[Applaudissements]
très bonne
Koweit
[Musique]
peut-être que moi, qui était vivant, j'ai été emmené
très facile
[Musique]
ce qu'ils font
et
Ouais
Un habitant
[Musique]
bien
si tous les êtres
c'est comme ca
bon
Phoenix tel et ça n'a pas été festif
et
[Musique]
quand elle
au nuage et à pecci aussi
[Musique]
Ouais
jusqu'à la chambre
[Musique]
Il n'a jamais mis de pages avec un nom possible
est délivré, ce qui supposerait 5 points de
Molina Martin et Sin Fin
et
[Musique]
d
c'est aussi simple que ça
[Musique]
peut-être ici
Oui oui
cette lumière et la capuline des autres
elle
le lion
Ouais
Salut
[Musique]
Mme
et quelle honte
[Musique]
ça se sent
ami
[Musique]
Ouais
Je sais que je vis
[Musique]